i knew that i wanted to be a part of
this show the euphoria cast is stacked
with talent but what really comes as a
shock is that for many this marked their
first leading role i'm like this is
crazy actors were literally brought in
from the street and interesting
instagram profiles while one actor had a
role specifically written for them let's
dive into how 12 of the euphoria actors
joined the team
number one the fact is we almost didn't
get zendaya's emmy award-winning
portrayal of roo casting director mary
venue was keen to have the actress
audition and she didn't have a hard time
convincing sam levinson she would be
perfect he actually included a photo of
the actress on his mood board developing
his lead character fangirling much
levenson but then again who can blame
him the bump in the road was in day's
team they weren't totally convinced that
the actor who'd risen to fame by a
disney channel should be crossing over
into such intense material while it
seemed nearly out of reach compared to
the sorts of roles we've seen her in
before when sendaya read those pages at
the last minute no less and there was
just like an immediate like um she knew
this was the part she had to play
number two
from instagram to the hbo screen the
hunter shafer story the euphoria casting
directors were looking for trans talent
and then along came hunter schaefer's
instagram and the audition offer came
through her modeling agency just shortly
after a few auditions with the help of
an acting coach later schaefer was one
of three being considered for the role
by the way none of these people were
trained actors when hunter gave her
audition it felt effortless and seamless
it happened like i got cast it's just
the wildest process over like a few
months i would say while the creative
team saw a lot from the actress the one
thing they'd never seen before diving
into filming was how schaefer and
zendaya would work together we didn't do
like a chemistry test yeah luckily their
chemistry was not an issue at all as we
get to see in their romance on screen
thank goodness for amazing creative
instagram profiles
number three who's that on the street it
might just be a star angus cloud was
minding his own business walking down a
street in new york when a casting rep
laid eyes on him this kind of thing
doesn't happen every day so it made
sense that cloud was suspicious and
worried he was being scammed until he
said yes and made a tape for the
creative team taking liberties to change
bits in the room to suit how he'd play
the character and it was perfect the
casting director knew he was 100 there
already in terms of pez's character so
it's no surprise that after the callback
session the actor was flown to la to
shoot
not having any experience cloud actually
resorted to some youtube acting
tutorials on the flight over but at the
end of it imma just show up and do what
they want and then be done clearly this
method works
number four
the first time around sweeney rejected
her euphoria audition after learning the
character would need to appear topless
the actress decided it wasn't the job
for her because i was too nervous to do
it the casting team didn't let the
rejection knock them down though and
tried sweeney again and thank goodness
she gave it a shot i fell in love with
the rawness and the situations and the
emotions levinson sweetened the deal
sharing what the character had ahead
when he told me her arc i absolutely
fell in love
sometimes fate has a way of working out
number five
seven auditions later barbie joined the
euphoria fam her first major role was
definitely a good one i'm reading the
sides which is like you know one scene
and i'm like even the way she talks is
very similar to me the audition came
through her agent and she was keen but
working as a model for so many years
left her worried that people would have
a hard time taking her seriously as an
actor i was felt so closely to this
character that during the audition
process i just my anxiety was mounting
like with every time i went in all that
pressure was a struggle but evidently
this actress works well under pressure
because after her final callback there
was no question she was cat
number six
a wicked musician an effortlessly
talented actor what can't he do a
collaborator of paul mccartney halsey
and justin bieber fike isn't short on
talent while dominic only joined the
euphoria fan for the second season he
was actually considered from the very
beginning of the series the actor came
close in his first round of auditions
but nothing came of it since the
character got cut from the show but that
didn't mean dominic had no future in the
world of euphoria no no about a year
after his first audition he was brought
in once again and uh well we know how it
went that time the role was bigger and
even closer to who the performer was as
a person
i don't have to do much acting
whatever he's doing it works no doubt
about it
number seven
does she look familiar it might be
because we've practically watched her
grow up on screen maud apatow spent
plenty of time on set with her parents
judd apatow and leslie mann even digging
into her acting skills for a few of them
sam levinson got to know the actress
working on assassination nation and when
he started developing characters for
euphoria mod's voice was in his head for
levinson it was always mod with the part
literally being written for her slipping
into character was no trouble at all we
are similar in our demeanor interests
and sensitivity
number eight
no money no job and then euphoria
not a bad deal he was young broke and
nearly homeless in la when the euphoria
script landed in his hands but the first
impression wasn't so great and lordy
thought nate was a jerk but that didn't
mean he was gonna pass up on the chance
to read and when the audition finally
came well let's just say the actor
wasn't saying all the lines they wanted
he straight up forgot a lot of them
during the audition fortunately those
acting chops of his were good enough and
he made a solid enough impression to
make it to callbacks until one day they
were filming for real
number nine one role lost another role
gained augustine friselle first caught
wind of alexa demi when she auditioned
for never going back while that gig
didn't work out frizzell was keen to
work with demi so a year later she
reached out about euphoria after getting
a steady stream of scripts she wasn't
really inspired by euphoria changed all
of that for demi i was able to see the
entire world and the music selection it
was just a dream script everything
seemed to fall into place when this
audition came around including stumbling
upon a cheese called euphoria in a
random deli shop beforehand if that
wasn't a sign we're not sure what was i
knew i had to be part of this why is
everyone like so dramatic
number 10 is he even allowed to be on
set alone
young wanna is fresh to the acting scene
and just 15 years old but he doesn't shy
away from that tough content with an
extraordinary amount of maturity he's a
boxer a gymnast and evidently a natural
actor and star on the rise one of the
casting directors jennifer benditti had
seen the newcomer's work and went
through his dad hoping his parents would
allow him to audition for the series
it was of course the perfect fit
when the euphoria team needed a younger
version of him the actor's baby brother
delos stepped in walton's brother really
wanted to perform and when he gave him a
shot it was perfect so sam levinson
brought the bro team on much to walton's
delight for him to be able to be part of
acting now and be on this journey with
me it's just so awesome
number eleven
hunter schaefer wasn't the only one to
be discovered by instagram chloe cherry
has worked as an adult film star for
years and after finding her instagram
page sam levinson was intrigued and the
casting agency worked to convince cherry
to audition he just thought i was funny
hey if it works it works to see it all
close up is just so incredible
number 12
from the background to the foreground
there is no stopping this up-and-comer
rebecca louise was hanging out in the
euphoria set working as an extra when
she got bumped up to a speaking role a
dream come true for sure to make the
deal even sweeter her first day on set
was finished off with a fist bump and
compliments from zendaya herself just
goes to show you never really know how
close you are to your dreams becoming a
reality
this cast is something special luckily
the creative team didn't stop trying to
find the best of the best no matter how
unusual the method they used who says
you can't find a star off the street